we'll just get into this stuff because
this is from cbs news minneapolis
approves historic 27 million dollar
settlement with george floyd's family
they say the city council voted 13-0
to approve the settlement which directs
half a million dollars to be used
to benefit the george floyd memorial
site at 38th and chicago
you know what that means uh i'm gonna
build a suspense on y'all for a minute
thirteen to zero this past weekend yeah
the george ford memorial site which is
an autonomous zone someone was shot and
killed
the city has just announced they are
going to fund this anti-autonomous zone
to the tune of half a million dollars
that's the degree to which this insanity
i'm sorry james you may say that you're
a little pessimistic but boy am i
getting pessimistic on this one
27 million dollars in a civil settlement
to the family look i'm i'm upset that
guy died
i don't like it when anybody dies 27
million historic why
because the terror worked that's right
the burning down the cities
it worked that's right so what are you
gonna see
more fire yep yeah they're giving half a
million dollars to these people
now the crazy thing too is chauvin is
still on trial
and so you have these jurors who are
supposed to be coming in and being asked
if they can remain impartial
and now they're gonna be told you know
in the civil case
they've already won clearly he must be
guilty of something the city's agreed to
settle
how can this guy get a fair trial o.j
simpson lost a civil case once after
that wasn't it i think the silver case
was after the criminal case though in
his case
it's funny um i don't know the history
of civil case criminal case the
the ad the adjunctives of it like if do
you is there a precedent for doing a
civil case first finding them i'm not a
lawyer i have no idea i do know that
you know this was a wrongful death and
that he's being tried for murder one
right
no uh murder two three and manslaughter
okay so yeah who knows then
um because the city is sort of admitting
admitting fault here
yep and uh i can't see that
i don't see how you yeah i mean i mean i
guess theoretically
maybe the judge will be like no no no
you've got to separate that and maybe
when it comes to the the defense they'll
say
a settlement is not an admission of
guilt the city just simply thought
paying out would be less expensive than
the damage and he might actually say
the fact the city thought 27 million
dollars was
cheaper than fighting the suit shows
what they really feared was the riots
from the extremists who are trying to
destroy the city
well yeah of course i mean that's what
the whole gig is an extortion gig
uh i get that there's like oh there's
the passion people are locked down i
don't want to like deny the ab you know
that
what was the the saying we had to endure
it was a quote from
from martin luther king but i felt like
it was taking a bit out of context
which was uh that a riot is the the
voice of the unheard or something like
that
and i get it people are locked down for
months people are like kind of out of
their
their minds looking for something to do
there's this flash point everything goes
crazy
but um
it's an extortion gig the the whole
because because the theory underlying it
if we look at critical race theory is an
extortion gig it works on
public relations they're not riots but
it also defends things like looting
there was that book
defense of looting that's all rooted in
critical race theory and i was crazy
stuff
that was written about ferguson i was in
ferguson
and when that article came out i threw
up in my mouth a little bit
it was it was like reading that was
a combination of several different uh
what's the right word for this like like
violations
of ethics the first was
to see the people desperately defending
their their town
their their their neighborhood from
these violent rioters and looters were
exploiting them
to see the manipulation and fake news
and the corruption of the media
it was like all at once and i was like
oh in ferguson
the kids who lived there some young men
linked arms
around the convenience store and they
were trying to defend the businesses
from the looters who came from out of
town
to exploit and steal and burn things
down because they thought it was funny
and they didn't care
and then along comes these ultra woke
white progressives from the suburbs
who have no idea what it's like to live
in poverty cheering
on the criminals who invaded this
neighborhood
and attacked the poor marginalized
people who lived there
and i witnessed it that's in ferguson
right thousand ferguson okay yeah so
what happened in in minneapolis is you
know the person who's now the vice
president coming out and saying this
needs to continue
let's bail them all out of jail here's a
link to the fund kamala harris kamala
harris yeah yeah
and people thought that if she got
elected that i i this is true
that she was the the tough cop the top
cop she was going to come and put an end
to this anti-fuss stuff this this
violence
and uh i remember talking to uh some
people i know in the chicago suburbs
they were talking about why they were
supporting biden and i was like don't
you think that under biden these these
extremists are emboldened and the rights
are gonna get worse
and there are people who said dude
kamala is like was like locking up
innocent people
pretty sure she's gonna go nuts and i
was like dude she tried bailing these
people out
she she solicited funds to get them out
of jail what's happening now
they said the they set the mark o
hadfield court courthouse on fire again
in portland that's right yeah and
speaking of portland you know i remember
talking to some folks that i'm friends
with in portland
and um their big concern going into the
election these are people
lifelong democrats or progressives or
leftists or whatever as
portland would do and um their concern
was
well our city isn't protecting us our
state isn't protecting us you'll get
this
ted wheeler the mayor you look at was it
kim brown isn't her name the governor
of oregon maybe i've got kim wrong but i
think that's right
and then the last line of defense it's
like trump
and you know he can't his hands are
tight he can't even send in like federal
troops or
the national guard or anything and then
their concern was you know if biden and
harris win
now every level of government whether
city state
or federal is going to do nothing to
protect the city of portland and now
like you said that was the federal
courthouse was on fire with people
inside right it was set on fire with
people inside
law enforcement and they had to rush out
and try to put the fire out yeah
do you think they should have sent the
feds in that trump should have sent the
feds in
i mean it's complicated right there is
the
the way that antifa works and a lot of
people don't understand this and if you
say oh it's black lives matter when it's
not antifa sometimes it is there's
this wing of black lives matter that i
think is called black lives matter
revolution but we could look that up
the that's the activist wing the
paramilitary ring the way that they work
is what's called
inducing mid-level violence a lot of
people don't understand that there are
levels of violence or how violence works
and what mid-level violence is is that
kid the brothers right in the back of
the car i'm not touching you i'm not
touching you i'm not touching you
and what they want is you to either back
down and show weakness
or to overreact and so we were referring
to this over the summer as the trump
trap
is that if he sent in federal troops aha
he's a fascist he's sending in federal
troops on american citizens that was
the narrative was there this whole game
is driving narratives we see this
with what's happening in minneapolis now
you see it there
the entire operative or operation of
what's happening is a narrative driven
maneuver where you have a collusion
between big media the democratic party
to seize power and the narrative is the
thing
so the game was to put trump in a
lose-lose situation oh he's too weak he
didn't do anything to protect anybody he
didn't do anything
but if he had done it the narrative
would have slipped the other way oh he's
a fascist see we've been telling you for
four years we've been conditioning you
for four years
trump's a fascist he's going to seize
power he's going to take over everything
and now he's sending federal troops
against american citizens that's exactly
what would have happened
so his hands were tied from what i
understand he was also told you know
by by military brass if you make this
order we won't follow it
and so what's he going to do you know
then he gets put in the same trap now
with these other people he has to
force them or or back down and look weak
and the same narratives are going to be
able to get spun out of this and this is
what people don't understand and i mean
i don't want to make this like left
right or whatever but the
radical left understands narrative and
political warfare
and nobody else does and so that's how
they keep catching everybody with their
pants down political warfare is the most
important concept you've never heard of
and political warfare are foreign
adversaries
reported a few decades ago i think china
and russia both
had had remarked that the american
ability because we rely so much on
physical warfare
we have such high technology we have bad
ass jets you know the whole thing
we don't even think about political
warfare anymore they said that it's so
degraded
that it might as well not exist and this
is what we're losing right now is
political warfare and
the radical left is trained they're
excellent at it they think about it
constantly
and they put people in these traps these
mid-level violence traps
we're particularly susceptible to it
because this country
is classically liberal and that and i
know a lot of people need to understand
what that means classically liberal that
doesn't mean conservative or liberal in
the colloquial sense
it means believing in freedom and
government for of by the people
things like that so this country is a
constitutional republic with
philosophically
liberal values liberal as a term seems
to have just
gradually evolved to mean i guess
democrat so but it was like john locke
that invented right right classical
liberalism is
is much more similar to like
center-right libertarianism
if anything and then social liberalism
is the civil rights kind of era people
who believe in free speech
and respect for you know people and
everything like that so that that came
about but
those of us who occupy this like
moderate libertarian space
kind of left kind of right maybe
depending on who you are uh well we're
playing fair
and we believe in respecting the rights
and speech of the of the uh of our
opponents
the problem then is i routinely stand up
and defend
leftists who get censored they gloat and
laugh
when it's us getting censored that's
right or i will
absolutely and i did defend taylor
lorenz
in this in the wake of this uh you know
criticism
of her because she this woman from the
new york times put out a tweet saying
that
you know her life was literally
destroyed by harassment i saw a tweet
and i thought it was a silly thing to
say but
i'm not going to be bothered by yelling
at someone on twitter simply because i
thought something they said was silly
otherwise my
my whole day would be nothing but that
well she started getting a lot of
criticism and i just ultimately said
look i get it if you want to criticize
the idea in the institution please do so
but you know getting into the weeds and
getting into the drama i think is
is a waste of our time i absolutely
tweeted in her defense multiple times
made videos in her defense
because i don't like the idea of people
piling on and engaging in this culture
war drama and then
not only uh i won't go into details but
now there's literally a harassment
campaign
being fun being promoted by large
powerful institutions
putting insane and ridiculous lies out
about me talking about where i live and
my home
and and absolutely engaging in a
targeted harassment campaign and they're
all laughing about it
they're all laughing about it so i can
stand on principle and say like let's
not do this guys
and then what happens then is the people
on you know the anti
you know woke side the people who
believe in freedom say it's warfare and
we have no choice they started it
that's the problem you know i believe in
a principle
and if my principles are we don't do
these tactics then i am at an extreme
disadvantage
where i can only get i can sit back and
turn the other cheek when they do these
things to me
to my family to my friends but if we
dare speak up
you know glenn greenwald points this out
they will come for you and they will use
the weight of all of these institutions
to destroy you
and even when i still defend them they
don't care
they are bad people now this is why i
say that i mean i've written an article
i think i did a podcast
both of these things that i actually
called wokeness but it could be radical
leftism in general
or even any certain totalitarian strain
the i called it radical left wokeness in
particular i called a
virus on the liberal body politic it
takes advantage of certain liberal
cultural and ethical mores specifically
to to do exactly as you just described
to absolutely
neuter the host ability to defend itself
your immune system's not there
you know uh i like to actually kind of
say frankly i've kind of
gotten hard about cancer culture and my
my belief there is that the asymmetry is
the story
it's no longer it's just it's not
culture war there's there's a power grab
happening i'm not quite as far as the
the
right we're like it's war we have to act
like war but the asymmetry is a story
and so for me until we adopt an attitude
if someone wants to cancel you cancel
them first
four or five times because it won't take
that many they that till there is a
realization that this is a
you know mutually assured destruction
that this that this horrific thing's
going to continue but
what it requires is a suspension of
one's
principles as a classical liberal which
puts us in that decision dilemma yet
again
and also by the way i don't know if it's
called is it gfas is that the george
floyd autonomous zone is that i guess
yeah but no that's the same thing though
right just wanted to point out well
since we don't so we don't lose it
that's also mid-level violence right
and the city has decided to show
weakness by giving them 20 whatever half
a million dollars
yeah so uh their other option of course
is to send in the troops and just
bulldoze this
they won't do it apparently it's been
there for like nine months they put in
half a million dollars now as part of
this settlement
and someone just died there recently and
the police couldn't get in to help this
person
so i'll i'll say this now my opinion
very much change in the autonomous zones
i'm here for it you know what roll with
it i left these cities
you know i i it's funny i'm in the
philadelphia area previously
and i was like there's too many riots
and they cross the bridge and they're
coming into these neighborhoods
so i think it's time to start
considering not being in these cities
because
it's not about antifa it's not about
black lives matter it's just about
opportunistic violence when things start
you know going crazy
and we had a year of riots well sure
enough i think it was like a week
after we we didn't move out officially
we we started the process
and came down to the new location riots
broke out mass shootings there was like
a hostage situation and i'm like
there you go man i mean homicides are on
the rise everywhere
so i think people need to realize i
think the last group of people i'm
worried about in a big city
is people like antifa i mean a lot of
these people are like suburban privilege
scrawny you know
angsty youths i really don't care my
bigger concern in philadelphia there was
a bunch of armed dudes
like repeat offender criminals occupying
buildings and shooting at cops
and you've got that kind of crime you've
got the homicide skyrocketing you've got
the gun crime
skyrocketing you've got just theft
across the board even petty theft and
these crimes in in a lot of these cities
partly due to the demoralization of the
police the defense hold on hold on
nobody knows why it's happening so
that's what i learned with the media
yeah nobody knows last summer it was
because it was summer
and in the winter maybe it was because
it was winter but i don't i don't know
but nobody knows yeah they're like you
see in the summer
uh it's it's it's warm giving more
people the opportunity to go out and
more people outside means
more crime will happen right
right and in the winter it's darker
which means a more opportunity to commit
crime
and then in the springtime as the
weather sets getting nicer people want
to go back outside again so then crime
just
in it just exponentially increases
non-stop has nothing to do with
defunding
the police nothing to do with uh you
know demoralization of police
just happenstance just nothing to do
with telling them to stand down nothing
to do with da's letting people off if
they get arrested
nothing to do nothing to do nothing
nothing to do with the city of
minneapolis putting half a million
dollars into an anti-pho autonomous zone
hey we're at that point now where it's
like the autonomous zone has
official government sanction you know in
this place
and it's it's it's remarkable so
where where where the conservative or
right-wing autonomous zones because i i
i mean this is right here in this house
really no i'm talking about no no no not
at all what i what i'm specifically
talking about
was uh uh when are we gonna start seeing
right-wing dudes
standing in the road the hype the the
u.s state highway or whatever
that leads into a small town of a few
thousand people city blocks
just doing checkpoints they did this in
the pacific northwest when the wild
fight when the fires kept starting
and this is one of the things you know
joe rogan i'm uh you know one of the
things i'm disappointed with him about
is that
he had said on his show he was wrong he
made a mistake that you know antifa is
going on starting these fires
he then made an apology which said none
of it was true it's not happening
the issue was that there was a guy who
was like a leftist who was caught
starting the fires
and there were other people many who
were not politically affiliated who were
just crazy firebug types
so you need to explain to people when
these photos came out showing right wing
dudes
with signs saying you know checkpoint
and then they were explaining people are
starting fires the media made it seem
like conspiracy crackpots were tracking
were scared of antifa
sure some of them were there was one
story about a leftist who got arrested
but a lot of irregular people like i
don't care who they are or what their
affiliation is they started fires
and there was a handful of people across
the the west coast that did
so you know joe's apology kind of just
got it wrong
but it's you know it's fine i don't
think he was it was intentional but
there's there are a lot of
people on the left that absolutely
engage in ongoing and sustained violence
and over the past year it's only worked
so so my point is
and they're opportunistic to that stuff
right yeah when are we going to see
in response to these autonomous zones
right-wing groups just
setting up in their communities there
was a viral video where you know
anti-foot group went into a neighborhood
in colorado and a bunch of regular guys
just
chased them out and uh did not go well
for those guys
because actual working class like union
boys
they're not scrawny suburbanite
privileged white kids
no they're men who went out and were
basically like
welcome to my neighborhood and the
interview people ran off
so i'm wondering if the city is going to
give half a million dollars
to benefit the george floyd memorial
site at 30th in chicago
which has become an autonomous owned
lockdown where black-clad individuals
threaten journalists and refuse to let
police in the police haven't been in in
months apparently
when do we see conservatives have a
peaceful autonomous zone
where they set up checkpoints i mean you
know the answer to that question
never and the answer is because the left
owns the political warfare like i just
said it's the most important concept
you've never heard of
and uh why what's going to happen well
you know what the media is going to do
with immediately
it could be as peaceful as peaceful it
could be literally doing nothing but
growing flowers
feeding the feeding the hungry you know
bringing out whatever the
most pro-social thing you can possibly
imagine is and it's going to be a crazy
right-wing militia group of kkk blah
blah blah
what they're going to say about it and
it's going to be white supremacist white
supremacist white supremacist
and because those words those ideas it's
not just that they have power
because that's one thing it's actually
that they stick like the word
conservative
as somebody who like is never identified
as one has been
tainted almost to the point of like
absolute
i guess taint has just completely
poisoned and so
conservatives seem to understand this i
put this on twitter a while back
um and i said that the meme is mightier
than the ar-15
and a bunch of gun guys were like well
i'll show you mine i'm like shut up
it's like shut up it's not true the only
ar-15 rounds that were fired i don't
know how many actually fired but three
hit people from
from kyle rittenhouse right yeah he had
two two three rounds
yeah so the only rounds that came out of
it out of an ar-15 were
like those like all summer there abouts
you know approximately and why
because every law-abiding gun owning
citizen knew
that the second somebody opened fire
guns are gone you know or the bid to
take guns is going to start and they
knew the meme
the meme of gun-toting right-wingers and
look what happened to kyle like
that was brutal yeah the meme was
actually more powerful an ar-15 that you
can't fire because you know it's going
to get turned against you in the
narrative war
and you're going to lose that political
war over it that meme is more powerful
than
the gun it's an ancient thought the pen
is mightier than the sword yeah that's
what i was i mean it was riffing yeah
it's like it's an ancient i didn't
listen listen i didn't quite think of
that one myself
i'll tell you what the real divide is
right so you've always always been like
a fairly liberal person
yeah i have as well yeah and ian i think
you are pretty like i used to be super
liberal
what i mean super liberal like like
free everyone no go we don't need
weapons everything can be fine like just
pie in the sky
borders yeah let everyone in we can help
everyone like
all the time when i was when i was
younger i was like an arko punk
skateboarder
you know i could play baby i'm an
anarchist on the guitar and i still can
from against me and i know a lot of the
against me songs i love that band
and uh you know these days
it's it's it's all changed quite a bit
but the one thing that i think
defines uh the actual
war the culture war is those who read
beyond the headlines and those who don't
that's it
there's really good examples of examples
of this if you go online
and you can actually see it so i'm
actually i'm actually actually
interested
in maybe hiring a researcher to start
tracking this as a data point
to go to the subreddits of prominent
progressive youtube personalities and
read the comments and then actually
write it you know mark them for like
who read beyond the headline and who
didn't and then go to conservative ones
and do it because what i've noticed
recently is that as i've been browsing
the subreddits of several prominent
progressive youtubers
they don't actually read the articles
they'll comment on the headlines
and while it's true for most people when
i go to conservative
you know sites not not so much
and this is also exemplified in
left-wing memes about conservatives so
there was one that i saw uh
on reddit where they were mocking the
conservative subreddit
because the conservative subreddit made
a point about not allowing billionaires
the ability to manipulate and control
our elections and big tech and things
like that
and they were mocking conservatives as
if the conservatives were the ones who
did it to themselves and it's like
i don't understand if you actually read
what they're talking about they're
agreeing with you
like you've convinced them or do you not
agree with them anymore
the issue was the caricature of the
conservative from the headline
does not accurately represent the real
world and that's true for libertarians
be it left or right or centrists or
whatever
and so what i've found is why is it that
the people who you know follow you james
or would watch this show are
more likely to be informed is it because
of this show
no i don't think so it's because of the
nature of the individuals who would
watch the show yeah i agree
the people who go and turn on cnn and
hear wolf blitzer say
a bunch of white you know white
supremacists stormed the capital they go
wow
and they walk away and then you have the
headline that appears on twitter and
says
far right white supremacist storm you
know you know let's do a better example
you'll turn on cnn and they'll say the
white supremacist group the proud boys
you know their leader was arrested and
they'll go whoa then you'll see the
headline
white supremacist leader of proud boys
arrested and people will see the
headline go wow
and then people who are more inclined to
watch shows like this will say okay
click it and see a picture of a black
man as the leader of the proud boys and
go wait what
something doesn't make sense here yeah
something and that's like the red pill
moment no that's exactly right you
actually start reading the news that's
that's red pill level one right there
yeah um that's where you see
like the news the headline especially is
lying to you
right and then you start finding the
buried leads and then you start finding
the inconsistencies in the stories you
start noticing
you know that the reporting doesn't
match reality and then all of a sudden
you're like wait a minute
and what it's all been framed up to be
is like now you're a conservative
right because you've read right but you
you're not a conservative you're
actually somebody who engaged with
information
like fully or at least more than almost
zero
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you